[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sa maman bébé d'abord 8 75 à 115 pour ma
part je travaille toujours bio ouais
mais ça va mais c'est pas toi tu as ton
bureau d'air
oui je vais rouler tout le temps je
trouverais cela ils bossent ils
préparent cyborg on a tourné à sketches
aujourd'hui ou de verre et la semaine
prochaine les mines au bureau risque non
match ou que note me donne l'adresse du
bureau sur ses vraies gens à l'adresse
de chez vous 50 avenue marcel-dassault
compte at il lancé
non non non ces rubans cgt avait évolué
c'est une avenue à aa
ça va tolérer comment ça pas mal ça va
tranquille où tiens tu m'a mis un petit
coup là c'est normal énormément du coup
comment
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
humour et castagne ils n'arrêtent pas de
se taper pendant les casters de mecha
statut j'ai pu se moquer de passer ou
partir pardon avant une balade est ce
que clem prenez des gants et allez-y non
mais c'est vrai que tu menaces beaucoup
mais tu vas jamais au bout point là
c'est le chien qui aboie ne mord pas
t'as pas de couilles je l'avais leurs
quatre tas d'or c'est bon tu sais tout
ça la classe on va le bon allez 24 ans
tu es locaux c'est que ça puisqu'il
fallait pas rater ces dernières 24
heures à la téloche cette période à un
médiateur sur nrj 12 on a vu un papa
dire à sa fille le premier truc qui fait
si gagne au loto mais il se rend vite
compte que la bad et moyennes les vu la
réaction de l'enfant et désamorçant papa
devant le loto à la télé ce m'est arrivé
d'avoir gagné tu imagines si on gagne un
million d'euros
[Musique]
un enfant de stars ensemble il fait de
la télé comme ses parents en angleterre
écologie attention voici le fait du jour
cette jeune fille veut faire signer aux
eaux faire marrer les copines en tirant
la langue
absents drones regardez alger les
commentateurs sont tellement détente qui
bouffent des chips qui commente les
matchs du brésil
c'est ouf vraiment y aller paolini au
mas pignou ce gadget est bien beau
d'avoir donné de l'eau qui prend
rapidement une pensée pour ce jeune
homme apparemment pas près de voir ce
qui n'a pas près de se remettre de ce
qu'il avait hâté lire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
el papa papa au début c'est fait il me
tarde à blagues 1100 coûte 4 5 ans les 9
h 50 c'est ce qu'a dit benjamin castadi
qu'il a gagné au loto quatre fois on a
regardé ça au leur cuisine sur france 3
non ouais ouais ouais c'est une fiction
petite émission de cuisine en fait il ya
une journaliste qui part à la rencontre
d'artisans plein de cuisinier plein de
petits maraîchers
elle part avec son cadreur en fin de
reportage et un chef qui leur dit on
voit un petit coup on track c'est la
fête son cadre à résister à être un bon
moment pks tout le délire santé merci
santé merci messieurs merci messieurs
alors moi je vais pas avoir beaucoup
étonnant que lui d'ailleurs parce qu'on
a des bouleaux après aussi tiens
regardez ça pendant un sujet dans une
usine on a fait la rencontre de vladimir
c'est un ouvrier en plein boulot devant
les caméras santé regarder si on zoome
sur de l'avenir regardez moi ces
charlots il s'ouvrait pas un peu de
notre gueule de l'année rien foutu
effectué à l'école a aidé à 10 milliards
d'enquêté exclusive il suivait une
équipe de douaniers regarder ça ils ont
fait une belle prise ça passeurs de
drogue c'est gênant pour tout le monde
il passait de la droite quelques pas
sans surprise non dans la nuit 10 et des
ovules de méthamphétamine qu'on a saisi
dans le rectum du passeur
[Musique]
les gens qui cherchent à aa a et merci
matteo garrone non et ils sont très
écolo c'est grave en fin de tournoi elle
récupère la terre battue pour maquiller
bernard montiel
donc on a vu quelqu'un d'important donne
corps les roannais maintien de m quel
joueur aussi regarder vous le connaissez
forcément cyril dubreau schwartzmann de
toutes les filles manon arbitres du
match a du mal à cacher son crush vous
allez voir dieu qui les trognons cette
année c'était le dernier roland de
lionel chamoulaud on le sait aux
commentaires et on sent qu'il est en
train de lâcher prise au yoyo a dit haut
ce qu'ils pensent ça donne vraiment
envie de re signer les droits pour l'an
prochain en réalité un petit peu de mal
à se réveiller un peu comme ces joueurs
mais quelque chose qu'ils savent à
fatick dans l'équipement vous êtes le
plus moche quand même sur le sexe non
mais c'est pas chez vous c'est pas
beaucoup mais le public a du mal un
roland garros émotions et heureusement
pour passer les heures en direct sur
français ça permet d'avoir les exclus
avant tout le monde
comme quand serena williams downing pour
annoncer son force et c'est très
important enfin quasi regarder
conférence de presse à lionel c'est la
sensation du jour du poisson n'a pas de
son non match henderson schwartzmann
regarder aurait-il fait qu'à la fin on
avait l'impression d'assister à un match
entre motors et son neveu de sept ans
mais à la fin c'est au foyer mission
c'est
[Musique]
c'est au monde un bébé après parce que
parfois les femmes elles 71 et l'autre
il a deux mètres 06 ouais donc je vous
dis gaillard gardien des liens alors que
ça fait beaucoup
ça fait assez fan de tf1 on verra demain
donc pour moi je dis ah ah
soit vous faites le tour des stands et
marron combien cette fois de bien situer
bien légal ça d'ailleurs on perd un
match était un adepte a perdu en
demi-finale
bah ouais formidable c'est le sponsor
principal de m i 2 du tournoi de
sponsors à la france hors de rien du
tout par contre j'ai tjrs sorte que
quand vous soit que vous la dépouille du
sol comme france télé partir de roland
garros
ils ont un petit peu des entrées
gratuites c'est normal des sacrés d'un
comme on dit dans le monde
regardez par exemple la rédac de france
info avant le tournoi ça pullule de
journalistes cherchent le secoue
regardez la rédac pendant roland garros
haas est plus calme à tout le monde et
court suzanne lenglen un tu sens bien
forcément ça se ressent à l'antenne ils
ont même mis un stagiaire
regardez le gars est surpris en direct
il n'est pas à l'aise il sait pas quoi
faire ils s'attendaient pas être en
plateau
[Musique]
oh
c'est beau 29 magasins repris le pas sur
ces news real ya une experte qui parle
orthographe mais orthographe à 8h30
c'est un peu tôt pour que ce soit bien
clair et limpide ya derrière la sicile
de sont trois bons et bien ça s'arrête
c'est comme ça qu'on dit aux enfants
mais un gant dans ta main deux appels
sans ça fait 200 voix son admission en
appel trois te sont pas en cash qui est
[Musique]
étrange deux pirates ans doit trouver
l'enfant star de gilles verdez et
francis cabrel
j'ai mal à ma cabane de jardin en raison
de ses opinions
[Musique]
il ya une jeune fille qui était dans la
matinale de 6h météo la jeune fille la
météo que j'ai rencontrés dans la rue
qui m'a dit qu'elle vous connaissez
nouvel ensemble
c'est bon de chez moi disons qu'il est
en couple
sa veuve a paris vous en tout cas ouais
ouais 10h20 potes comme commencent alors
des liens belle et très sympathique de
râler la semaine dernière c'est dans la
rue tranquillement en train de faire du
dover board est l'un des rires qui vient
bois et qui me dit baba mais tombera
saint maxin give à jilib a écoutés a dit
spontanément
ouais bon elle a pensé à tout faire
ouais il est content des cons titue
attend avec autant est contraint par
balle et elle est en couple depuis on
espère qu'il va y avoir des cumulonimbus
aller sur 24 exclus ils sont partis en
polynésie ils ont découvert des animaux
une espèce assez rare urd leur première
étape
l'île aux oiseaux
[Musique]
oh
dans les maternelles regarde on n'était
pas prêt à entendre cette phrase sortir
de la bouche d'une chronicles devrait
devrait surtout de si bon matin j'en ai
craché mon mât qui a trait à la vélo
natation à ce qu'elle peut reprendre
selon moi j'en sais rien en fait j'ai
envie de dire il faudrait remettre les
douanes ont souvent je pense et on a
aussi regardé m6 boutique qui vend
toujours des objets d'un gi sont à fond
à vannes les experts vous propose ses
cinq à six mille comment tu passeras
moins de dix minutes c'est notre
opération aujourd'hui qu'il ne faut pas
manquer en a une super offre et ce matin
ils sont allés encore plus loin que
d'habitude un nouveau goodies qui a été
lancé apparemment on se demande où le
fameux slim maxime rap c'est cette
nouveauté incroyable vous allez voir
c'est quand même un chéquier à la maison
donc on va faire une version qui ont
encore deux maîtres drôle malgré des
habits
c'est vrai je suis hyper agréable auquel
les frères c'est le seul gala du poison
cactus mon frère c'est qu'ils ont connu
le gars o'connell on ne sait pas lui
rendre service
non non à dire merci benjamin bon je
voulais vous faire petite surprise est
encore sur le dois travailler encore sur
le sahara gâte tient alors oui alors
nous créé une petite surprise
quelle surprise et ne vais pas vous quel
rapport anna je crois que c'est
impossible tenir plus longtemps j'ai
maté les jeux de france télé notamment
le jeu de sega europe
personne n'y avait pensé mon petit doigt
me dit qu'un membre de l'équipe va pas
tarder elle est dans le village d'un des
candidats je pense rappelle que joël il
est maire de saint quentin les marais
c'est ça à côté de saint-amand-sur-fion
saint-amand-sur-fion
jérôme et tu sens que la loi
lafontaine taux d'intérêt donc moi je
suis gestionnaire de dossiers dans un
autre cas ab oui bah oui bah oui notre
cas bah oui je vous demande de vous
arrêter aux commandos contre ça passe
rapidement et un spectateur qui est
hyper furieux jusqu'à petit entendu katy
perry la route fer en 2008
et enfin étonné sur ce couple brésiliens
qui ont été exposés à des images chèques
fiable une pensée pour eux courage
[Musique]
ça et c
à l'epo dernière petite chose je vous
laisse tranquille juste j'ai regardé
idf1 aussi à isabelle 2 et son collègue
ils sont hyper à l'aise sont cools ils
sont très proches vraiment des gens qui
les appelle ça fait plaisir
merci votre appel à bien et puis on
espère que le message va passer oui on
croise les doigts pour toi olivier
attachez-vous w9 c'est une candidate qui
est personnel entre les lattes solution
pour résoudre un conflit
sauf elle a oublié l'essentiel pour le
reste était si les malades mais détruit
les munitions
il voulait pas aller
donnez lui dire en espagne et ya donné
par un français à avoir remporté un
match
un golfeur américain décide de pedro la
chance avec celle dont il amoureux
depuis dix ans et allez prenez exemple
team
il a gagné la compagnie qui se lance
[Musique]
c'est beau ça moment c'est le moment et
non
à votre avis adele est le faux nez tout
en juillet
[Applaudissements]